i think
here's something that always interests
me about about the
fighters in general like choking people
unconscious
it's just it's it's to a lay person it's
such a
shocking and like crazy concept but to a
professional fighter
choking someone out is is really like
not not a very big deal
right it's like a party trick kind of
yeah well i mean to be honest
just fighters or jiu jitsu or anyone
that does martial arts basically yeah
not too big of a deal i mean if you're
doing jiu jitsu
you know you'll start your session
you'll do some technique whatever
at the end you roll you know you might
do five five minutes of rolling and
that's what you're trying to do you're
trying to put
your jujitsu to use you're trying to
choke people out tap them out
on bar knee bar whatever it is you're
trying to make them submit so yeah it
definitely
feels second uh second nature it doesn't
feel weird whatsoever you know and
the more you do it you know you do kind
of become desensitized to it and the
more you watch the ufc you become more
desensitized to it i remember when i
first saw the ufc i was like holy [ __ ]
because
well i saw it a long time ago i was in
new zealand in 1995 for jiu jitsu world
championships and
that was the first time i saw it then
but i'm talking about uh 2002
uh some an old trainer came to me and
said hey there's this thing called the
ufc
it's getting pretty big i think you'd be
good at it and it's all right [ __ ] it
let's go so i gave it a shot without
even seeing it and then my wife got me
uh ultimate knockouts or ultimate
submissions or something for christmas
and i sat down with my boys
in 2002 and we watched it with beers in
hand they're like
this is what you're getting into michael
i'm like [ __ ] yeah looks like
it thank you so much for watching this
clip
and guess what i have the number 30
ranked hot sauce on
all of amazon it's called stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude